[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and this
is the oneplus 7t
so if you follow the leaks aka promo
you've probably seen pretty much every
angle of this thing but now it's
officially been unveiled i've been using
it daily for about a week
and this is a pretty easy phone to
explain so oneplus the company they have
their sort of upper mid-range phones
somewhere around 500 600 like oneplus 7
then they have their premium high-end
flagship stuff like oneplus 7 pro that's
closer to seven eight hundred bucks so
this phone the oneplus
7t
kind of kind of a hard name to say out
loud it's not the 70 but it's the
oneplus 7t
this phone is sort of a frankenstein
between those two groups it's right
between the super high end and the upper
mid range
if that makes any sense so to be
perfectly clear it is a really great
phone for the price which is basically
the one plus special at this point
they've continued this fascinating slow
creep up in price but when you go over
this phone and everything they've
combined in here
it's pretty on point for what you're
getting for 599 bucks so this display is
a perfect example right so just look at
this screen the whole phone is really
big as you can tell but that's because
it's got this huge 6.55 inch oled screen
it's just barely smaller than the 7 pro
actually and that's a huge phone but
you have the teardrop notch at the top
from the 7 and it's a flat screen now
instead of one of those panels that
curves around the edges and i'm down
with that and it is 90 hertz so this is
as far as i know i guess the cheapest
phone with a high refresh rate display
like this and i'm glad they brought that
down that's becoming a signature
characteristic of these phones so
overall it's a nice combination of
things despite not being the highest end
display you know it gets pretty bright
up to a thousand nits so outdoor
visibility is no problem and the
teardrop notch being a little smaller
makes it super easy to ignore on this
gigantic screen but it's also 1080p not
1440 and the bezels are just a little
bit thicker a tiny bit as you can see
and i have noticed some real off-axis
color tint and rainbowing and other
consistencies like that that you'll
notice on not so high-end oled displays
so it's not the super best of the best
but it's like right
underneath it's right in between it's
making sense right they're bringing
things down from the higher end phone
that makes sense while keeping the sort
of baseline of the mid-range the higher
fresh rate i think is the most important
thing that they brought down that i just
i love me some 90 hertz some high
refresh rate goodness so that's good to
see and then just the design of this
phone in general is also a bit of a
frankenstein you've probably noticed it
by now there's this aura blue color
again
although this time it's not as matte as
before it's kind of closer to like a
satin because it has more of a sheen to
it it's not really glossy like some
other phones but you definitely do still
see fingerprints much more than a matte
phone so it's somewhere in between again
the 7 pro is more matte than this one
but here's some other improvements you
do have the alert slider is tighter so
it's more satisfying to move between the
three positions so that's pretty sweet
they brought down the high-end really
precise haptic motor that's honestly
only really matched on android by the
pixel at this point so that was great
and they brought the optical fingerprint
reader underneath the glass that's also
the same sensor as the one from the
seven pro and i think one of the best in
any phone under the glass right now the
speakers are also just as good as the 7
pro they sound loud and full and there's
also a bigger speaker grow up at the top
and charging is now even faster so
they're calling it warp charge 30t
it's still a 30 watt fast charger but
thanks to improved battery chemistry in
the 3 800 milliamp hour battery in this
phone it'll charge 23 faster than warp
charge 30 already did so in other words
it's silly fast and it's kind of a you
know a different philosophy on battery
management on one hand i love you know
the little chunkier phones that'll have
this massive battery inside an all-day
battery life it changes the way i use
phones i didn't worry about charging
ever during the day but on the other
hand a phone that's really trim like
this that has
crazy fast charging just lets you have
this peace of mind that anytime you're
starting to get low you can just plug in
for a couple minutes and be right back
up to 70 80 percent so that's like a
different kind of confidence in the
battery i don't really have a preference
between the two it would be great to
have both but uh as of right now i like
having this warp charge 30t they say
will get you to 70
from dead in half an hour and that's
awesome and i believe that but i'm even
more impressed by just how much you can
add from plugging in for five minutes 10
minutes and just giving you a massive
boost for the rest of the day so the 7t
does have decent battery life but this
is the steady compromise they make for
not having the best battery life and
then of course the gigantic
camera circle
on the back
uh it's genuinely i think the first
design from oneplus that doesn't feel to
me like really sleek or clean like
they've done triple cameras before even
but this one is very different it kind
of reminds me of somewhere between
motorola or the red hydrogen or you
might even remember the nokia lumia
series back in the day funny thing is
these are essentially the same exact
cameras that the oneplus 7 pro already
has same standard 48 megapixel standard
camera same 117 degree ultra wide and
then a shorter 2x telephoto zoom camera
instead of a 3x so if you're actually
looking for some big camera improvements
for the 7t
that is not what's happening here uh and
it's actually not like the oneplus 7 pro
camera was bad it's just that it was the
one part of the phone that wasn't you
know best in class world class it sort
of held it back from being an arguably
perfect phone in a way but in a 600
phone in 2019 this set of cameras is
perfectly good i've been taking photos
and videos with it just to see if i
notice any substantial differences
around but uh there isn't anything too
drastic still very solid in daylight and
a bit color fringy and soft around the
edges with close-up subjects
and passable but not amazing shots in
less than ideal lighting if you think
about other cameras in this 600 price
range that's about right actually uh
right up until they start to get blown
out the water by the seven hundred
dollar iphone 11.
you can take portrait mode shots now in
telephoto or standard cameras now which
is cool
and they are also enabling 4k 30fps
video from the ultrawide camera so
they've heard our feedback they are
going to do that and i think the most
impressive improvement here is the new
super macro mode so you hit this little
flower icon in the top corner and you
can get way up close to things uh 2.5 to
8 centimeters away from the camera lens
which most smartphones do struggle with
if they don't have a macro mode and so
with this i was able to take some
close-ups that i couldn't even get with
the iphone 11 and then of course this
wouldn't be a new oneplus phone without
really killer high-end on-paper specs
and so that's what they've done here
again so snapdragon e55 plus the newest
chip
eight gigs of ram not 12
and 128 or 256 gigs of ufs 3.0 storage
so yeah this thing is fast and it's
running the latest version of oxygen os
10 on top of android 10 which i think
makes this the first non-pixel android
10 phone i've used and it's been really
good so far i obviously love that
they're early to updates and performance
has actually been really smooth you may
have noticed i didn't keep the android
10 gestures the swipe gestures turned on
here's why android 10 gestures on this
phone are a swipe up from the bottom for
home
a half swipe up for multitasking and
then a swipe in from the lower side to
go back from anywhere you know what else
uses that swipe to go back on the side
a lot of android apps for other things
twitter to switch between accounts
flamingo for twitter
ticktick my tasks app youtube studio
google photos the play store i mean a
lot of google apps use that hamburger
menu and the screen is so big on this
phone that i don't really want to reach
up to the corner with one hand to press
the hamburger menu every single time
so i don't
so i turned it off and i just keep using
the buttons for now but aside from that
android 10 has been really nice really
smooth as you'd expect on a new phone
with a 90 hertz screen and all the
optimizations oneplus is continually
working on for oxygen os they really
show so all that for me using this phone
has added up to it being a pretty solid
set of trade-offs that add up to
a pretty good phone for pretty great
price it really feels like they're
taking the stuff that they learned how
to do better and more efficiently from
the 7 pro and bringing it down to a more
competitive price which is a great way
to sell a lot of phones now of course to
be perfectly clear the oneplus 7 pro
is still a better phone than this just
because of the small bit of trade-offs
they've kept a higher quality display
higher resolution not as much color
fringing and things like that uh bigger
battery uh less ugly camera bump on the
back and the notchless screen on the
front so all that sort of adds up to a
little bit of trade-offs here but
overall this is that incremental update
you expect from a t-phone from oneplus
with the x factor of that 90hz display
that is so hard to switch back from so
that's the statement that the phone
leaves me with is that i'm glad that
oneplus is doubling down on the high
refresh rate stuff to really make phones
feel smooth
high refresh rate all the things please
this is going to be a really good buy
for people who want to spend like 600
bucks on a phone but for me i'm
personally going to be pretty excited
about the oneplus
7t pro names are getting weird but
that's the phone that's going to have
the best of the best that i'm looking
forward to but yeah not bad i'll have a
link below if you want to check it out
that's been it thank you for watching
and i'll catch you guys the next one
peace
you